Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
So, Hank, today marks the 6th anniversary of Vlogbrothers.
But more importantly, last night the United States Senate
threw the worst New Year's Eve party ever
that ended with a compromise to avoid the so-called "fiscal cliff"
of increased taxes and decreased spending.
The centerpiece of this compromise is to make the really hard decisions in a few months.
So... CONGRESS!
John from the future here. Quick update:
When making this video I naturally assumed
that the House of Representatives would also agree to the compromise
so as to avoid intentionally throwing the nation into a recession
but it turns out... I may have been overly optimistic.
CONGRESS!
By almost any measure the last two years have seen
the least effective congress-ing in the United States
since at least the 1850's, which as you might remember
led to a Ken Burns documentary.
Hank, in the last 2 years the U.S. congress has only passed 219 bills,
which may sound like a lot, except almost all of those
were to name federal buildings after war heroes.
I mean, don't get me wrong, I am happy that
there is now a post office named after
Revolutionary War general Nathaniel Woodhull
who when ordered to say "God save the Queen" instead said "God save us all" and then got killed,
but that's it, Hank! That's all they've done!
I mean, the famous "Do-Nothing Congress" of the Harry Truman era
passed more than 900 bills!
So, Hank, to understand why the legislative branch
has become so incredibly ineffective at... legislating,
we need a quick history lesson.
The original American government was founded on the Articles of Confederation
and that government really couldn't do anything.
So we eventually had to ditch the Articles and write the Constitution,
which created a Congress that could do, you know, just a little bit.
So the United States congress, like a lot of rich people, lives in two houses.
There's the Senate, which has two members from each of the 50 states, who are elected to 6-year terms,
and then there's the House of Representatives, where people serve 2-year terms,
which means they're basically always campaigning.
Each state gets a certain number of representatives based on population,
so, like, Hank, in Montana you just have one because no one lives in Montana,
here in Indiana we have, like, nine.
And vitally, each state legislature draws its own lines for where the congressional districts begin and end.
And Hank, I think that turns out to be one of the central reasons why congress can't do anything.
Hank, my congressperson here in Indianapolis is Andre Carson. He's a Democrat.
My across-the-street neighbor, however, is represented by a Republican named Dan Burton.
Is that because we live in different zip codes? No, we live in the same zip code.
It's because the houses across the street are more expensive,
so they re-drew the district to include those houses
because they figure they'll vote for Republicans.
And Hank, this kind of thing is happening all over the country.
Like, according to analysis by Nate Silver,
in the last 20 years we've gone from 103 swing districts,
that is, districts where either party has about an equal chance of winning,
to 35 swing districts.
And today, because of the way state legislatures draw these maps,
most congressional districts are so-called "landslide districts",
which means they're at least 20% more Republican or more Democratic
than the American population.
Hank, if you're Democrat Andre Carson or Republican Dan Burton
you're gonna win your general election by, like, 30 percentage points.
So, in most congressional elections, the race between the Republican and the Democrat is not a race...
the only race, the only thing these people have to fear,
is a primary challenger, another Republican or another Democrat
coming in and saying "You're not radical enough!"
So why would you compromise when compromising can cost you your job?
Hank, 2012 was an amazing year for us...
you co-created the Lizzie Bennett Diaries and SciShow and Crash Course,
VidCon doubled in size,
My book "The Fault in Our Stars" was published and so far has spent
51 consecutive weeks on the New York Times Bestseller List,
why are these things happening?
Because government! Also Nerdfighteria.
Government, Hank. There's a reason why no popular
YouTube adaptation of "Pride and Prejudice" has emerged from Somalia...
they don't have a government. They don't have roads to facilitate commerce,
or public schools to teach kids, or investment in telecom to make... this happen.
So, Hank, congress was designed to suck at doing stuff.
And they do. But they have to work together just enough to cover, you know, the basics.
And we've always gotten there, but now I'm a little worried.
Now, Hank, people won't lose faith in America's ability to govern itself all at once...
it won't be an event, it'll be a process.
But if it happens, it will be much worse than going over any fiscal cliff.
So remember, the next time you vote the most important election
might be for, like, state congressperson
or whoever's gonna draw the line to decide
whether my neighbor and I should have the same congressional representation
even though we have different incomes.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
P.S., Hank, who would have thought we'd be doing this for six years?
Thank you, American government, for running well enough
that I can make videos in my basement
for Nerdfighters.
That sounded creepy, but it's not!